trouve tout de suite julie d'un goal of
depuis odessa bonjour julie on vient de
voir votre votre reportage qui ressort
notamment des nombreux témoignages que
vous avez recueilli ces c'est le
désarroi de la population dans cette
région qui qui s'attend à une offensive
russe
oui ça fait plusieurs semaines un codesa
est dans la ligne de mire russe et donc
il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes de la part
de la population à vous avez vu ce vieil
homme anatolie dont la maison a été
détruite on a pu parler également avec
ses voisins qui ne comprennent pas eh
bien qu'on ait pu les toucher eux de
simples civils des simples maisons très
modeste en bords de la mer noire ils
sont très en colère contre vladimir
poutine à l'atelier nous disait qu'à
chaque fois qu'ils traquaient eh bien
ils traquaient à la mort de vladimir
poutine c'est vous dire la haine qu'il
voue au président russe on a pu parler
avec de nombreuses personnes aussi dans
odessa ce que les gens nous disent c'est
que depuis que les sirènes recommence à
retentir dans la villa hier par exemple
les sont sonnés à six reprises et bien
l'inquiétude revient l'inquiétude
revient une jeune femme nous disait que
à présent elle avait l'impression que ce
ça rapprocher d'elle et c'est la
sensation que nous avons aussi bien sûr
bien parce qu'il ya eu ces frappes mais
aussi parce que je vous le disais de
nombreuses alertes pour demander à la
population de se mettre à l'abri
résonnent dans la ville ce que disent
aussi les gens c'est qu'ils se tiennent
prêts ce qu'on entend de la part des
autorités locales ici à odessa notamment
du maire et bien c'est qu'ils sont très
reconnaissants aux soldats russes qui
résistent ami collègue nicolas yves
c'est une ville à 130 kilomètres d'ici
nous avons eu l'occasion de nous rendre
et qui repousse l'offensive russe vers
personnes ici à odessa les gens scrute
ce qui se passe à micola yves parce
qu'ils savent très bien que cette ville
est présenté comme le dernier verrou
avant odessa avant une offensif plus
importantes sur odessa avant une
offensive éventuellement même terrestre
sur odessa la ville d'odessa s'organise
cependant on a pu voir depuis que nous
sommes ici de nombreuses personnes qui
tentent de participer d'une manière ou
d'une autre à l'effort de guerre par
exemple nous étions dans un restaurant
familial et cette dame qui tient ce
restaurant près par 250 soldats par 250
repas par jour pour les soldats excusez
moi qui donc sont envoyés ensuite au
front on a pu se rendre dans le marché
d'odessa qui est un endroit branché de
la ville où des dizaines de jeunes
s'activent pareil pour récolter des
médicaments des vivres il prépare des
paquetages qui eux aussi vont vers les
soldats non ici on tente de garder le
moral à odessa et de se dire qu'on est
prêt en cas d'une éventuelle offensive
russe